if you only had 10 exercises for the
rest of time that's all you have in your
library to stay as muscular as possible
give me the list if it's my whole life I
might actually do smth machine squats
because it'll help my knees and be a
little bit easier deadlifts just to get
something that'll Target my hamstrings
pull-ups overand under hand neutral oh
neutral gri neutral probably yeah it's a
little bit more Latin biceps incline
dumbbell press I find incline's a little
bit better on your shoulders and
dumbbell it just keep you a little bit
more symmetrical dumbbell shoulder press
seated seated dumbbell shoulder press
yeah I think that'll help your tricep
and shoulders a lot a close grip flat
bench I would probably do lateral raises
thinking what parts of the body I'm
missing right now Cals yeah there no
calves in there maybe I'll just do
stairs on the side and not tell you
about that okay fine you've still got
three exercises you only needed seven so
far did they say bent over a row no bent
over a row that'll help like stability
core as well and then like lower back
and obviously upper back a hanging leg
raise just to make sure your core is
getting hit dumbbell curl with that are
you super you seated you standing
standing super okay